let's talk about indoor air pollution
i remember when i first heard about
indoor air pollution in my ap
environmental science class
i was a little confused when i used to
think of pollution
i would think of images like this or
this
but pollution is often invisible and it
isn't just restricted to the outdoors
indoor air pollutants can lead to
serious health conditions
and even death but there are ways to
identify and prevent indoor air
pollution
let's take a look at an example this is
ava
and let's say ava like many other people
in the world spends the majority of her
time
indoors she works sleeps
cooks and eats in her home and lately
she's been experiencing headaches
and she's been coughing a possible
culprit is
indoor air pollution so where could the
indoor air pollution be coming from
let's take a look at ava's house indoor
air pollution can come from many
different kinds of sources
both human-made and natural ava's
furniture paneling and carpets could be
releasing volatile organic compounds
which are often written down as vocs and
they basically include substances that
form
gases at room temperature like
formaldehyde
formaldehyde is used as an adhesive in
building materials and upholstery
and it can get into the air this is the
same stuff that is used to embalm and
preserve
dead bodies in other words it's not
pleasant to breathe in
the united states environmental
protection agency says that formaldehyde
is one of the four
most dangerous air pollutants in the
country formaldehyde can make you dizzy
and nauseated and if you're exposed to
enough of it
it can kill you indoor air pollutants
can also come from ava's house itself
in the form of particulates which are
teeny tiny particles
so small that they can stay suspended in
the air and
they can be really dangerous because
they can travel deep into the lungs
and damage cells one such particulate is
asbestos
it's actually in my opinion a really
cool substance
it's an electrical insulator and it's
fireproof
and it's acid proof and there was a time
when many houses were being built
with asbestos and its building
insulation flooring and roofing
it's actually a natural material that's
mined
and it has light fluffy fibers that can
be woven into cloth
to me it always looks like unicorn hair
but really it's more like
evil unicorn hair each fiber can break
into microscopic pieces that could scar
your lungs
and lead to lung cancer and other lung
diseases
particulates in ava's house could also
be coming from the paint
lead paint in ava's house could begin to
chip away
and could suspend small particles in the
air
these particles could cause lead
poisoning which can cause headaches
and nerve and brain damage the use of
lead and asbestos has been restricted by
many governments around the world
but these materials can still be found
in older buildings
another way inside air can become
polluted is through combustion
which is to say burning stuff combustion
can cause a wide variety of pollutants
that can irritate lungs
including carbon monoxide nitrogen
oxides
sulfur dioxide and particulates
one way that carbon monoxide can build
up inside a building
is from a poorly maintained furnace
carbon monoxide molecules have
a secret weapon they can trick the
proteins in your blood
into thinking their oxygen this can
cause asphyxiation
which is when the body cannot get enough
oxygen and
it can be deadly ava should make sure
that our furnace is well maintained
and serviced regularly combustion
related air pollution
doesn't just come from furnaces though
in less economically developed countries
families sometimes use open fires for
heating and cooking
people often burn wood peat and even
coal inside homes without the necessary
ventilation to circulate and dilute the
pollutants in the air
combustion related air pollution can
also come from poorly ventilated
fireplaces
and tobacco smoke so
what could eva do to reduce combustion
related air pollution
well she could open the windows and she
could use fans to mix the smoke and
pollution with outside air
ava should also install a carbon
monoxide detector
to make sure that the air is safe a
carbon monoxide detector could also
detect leaks from natural gas stoves or
heaters
it's also possible that ava's house has
natural pollutants
like mold dust or even radon
mold is a type of microscopic fungus
that's always floating around in the air
and breathing it in can cause itchy eyes
runny noses
and it can trigger asthma attacks and
molds
loves moisture so when the air is really
humid
there will be more mold spores which is
good for the molds
but bad for us and what areas of the
house tend to have the most moisture
the bathrooms and the kitchen so these
areas especially need to have windows
that can be opened or air fans that can
draw moisture
and the molds out of the house another
kind of natural indoor air pollutant
is radon which is a radioactive noble
gas it's produced by the natural decay
of radioactive rocks
in the ground let's say that ava's
basement
has some cracks in the foundation in the
walls
that would mean that when radon seeps
upward through the soil
it could enter these cracks and be stuck
inside ava's house
breathing in too much radon could damage
lung tissue and
even lead to lung cancer depending on
where the house is built
some places like ava's house are more
likely to have radon
than others ava can prevent radon
exposure by sealing up the cracks in the
foundation of her house
and by ventilating her basement some
indoor air pollution requires
professional remediation to get rid of
asbestos
for example an accredited asbestos
abatement specialist
basically shows up in a biohazard suit
like this
that's how dangerous it is for other
situations
there is a simple solution to ava's
problem ventilation
ava could open windows on the opposing
sides of her home
just a crack the outdoor air would flow
in
dilute the indoor air pollutants and
carry them out of the house
this natural ventilation allows the air
to circulate
and reduces the buildup of indoor air
pollutants
there are a lot of ways that indoor air
pollutants could sneak into ava's house
from nature from combustion and from
human-made items
being aware of these sources can help
ava make sure that the air inside our
house is fresh
clean and healthy